there's like a
matrix kind of red pill blue phenomenon
i'm seeing from this that's causing
i'll just call it societal collapse and
what i mean to say is
when you're inundated by
a certain subject matter school
shootings police brutality whatever on
social media and then the algorithm
keeps feeding you that content and then
you come to perceive that as the only
existence as the real world
you're basically in this matrix you are
in you're in the algorithms world
now being fed these stories you'll
immediately become an advocate saying
like we have to stop this and you'll
start giving your energy and power to
politicians who don't actually care to
solve any problems just exploit your
fears
and then there are people who are sort
of
awakened to this right so the blue pill
red pill you're you're in and i'm and i
i i hate the political red pill blue
pill thing but i mean quite literally
like
there's an algorithm at play on social
media
crafting a world for people that makes
no sense because they click on police
brutality and the algorithm says let's
give them more of that it's good for
business for the company that they're on
the website more so let's do more
algorithmic content feeding and then
there are people who are just like i'm
sick of the algorithms i'm just going to
shuffle it up i want to i want wanna
read i'm gonna investigate on my own and
then they break out of that system and
say hey wait a minute something's not
right here now the problem is we're
having this conversation about the the
rarity of school shootings the the
rarity of unarmed black men being killed
by police both both circumstances
extremely awful and shouldn't happen and
we should do what we can to make sure
they don't happen but extremely rare so
for us to put you know 70 something
million kids through school shooting
trainings
because you said what do you say 10 well
done i think on average it's 10 it may
be a little bit more uh some years than
others but generally speaking more kids
die in pool drownings or in some kind of
drowning like they should swim lessons
would be more useful for children than
the school shooting drills let's see
here's what happens the people who live
in the matrix in this algorithm you know
or this median narrative or click bait
rage bait drift or whatever
start voting for policies based on a
fake world view that was fed to them to
make money
and that's why i think it's gotten so
substantially worse to the point where
it's like you know we feel like we're at
each other's throats there's there was a
literally uh
shootout this past weekend uh one of the
i guess a proud boy got shot in the they
were shooting at him and he got he took
a bowling leg it was uh i don't know if
he was a proud boy it was the guy tiny i
thought he was patriot pair but people
are saying proud boy and there was a
shootout a couple weeks ago in in
portland as well where thankfully nobody
got hurt
but what happens is
you have people
who will vote
who will run for office
and and it's it's not just like you live
in a matrix where there is an overseer
keep keeping you in the matrix like
people believe that they saw the movie
no no no the people who are running the
matrix live in it too
the people who are
taking the blue pill
who believe that there is like a a it's
it's a pandemic of police officers going
around hunting down black people they
run for office based on that and then
try and pass laws based on that
you try and tell them it's not real and
they'll snap at you they'll call you a
nazi a fascist all right they gotta
protect that worldview
i don't know how you break down i mean
look i the other day something i've been
writing about is basically pandemic
responses across the world because one
thing i noticed is that
the u.s response when it comes to uh
children is very different than most of
the world most of europe australia new
zealand uh you know we're we're
acquiring mass in most school districts
in the united states even for children
who are four or five years old six years
old which actually is much more
conservative than what the who
recommends it's more conservative than
what the european health agencies are
talking about or most of the australian
districts
and you know
to buttress my argument you know i just
put out a basic graph from the cdc
showing that child
mortality child deaths from covet 19 are
very very small they're a very small
percentage they've generally been the
same throughout the pandemic and you
know the instantaneous response you get
to that is that you're minimizing the
debts of children right i literally
posted the facts straight from the cdc
showing the context of this and i think
that you know part of it is that
i think once you've adopted the activist
mindset of the moralizing mindset you
have one goal in mind and that goal of
course is protecting children from
covenant 19 a totally understandable
goal
but at the same time when you're not
getting the whole picture you're not
looking at all the other possible
ramifications of keeping kids in this
crisis mode for basically forever and
you're not considering the points of
view of other people in the world who
are not doing that you know in british
schools they're not doing that in
australian schools they're not doing
that they're using largely rapid testing
social distancing uh some
some
vaccinations at the higher level like 16
and 17 year olds are maybe are getting
vaccinations but they're not having
toddlers running around in mass for the
most part
and uk's had the delta very you know
they've had this experience they've seen
this movie um and yet they're not doing
it i think we're not really giving any
weight to their to their concerns
because we fixated so much on one
problem
and that i think is really you know not
only is it corrupting journalism it's
corrupting society because i think we
need to be well-rounded people right a
bird can't fly with just one wing you
got to have two wings right you got to
be able to understand things from more
than one point of view and you have to
be able to look at more than one problem
in society because i think we've created
a lot of problems for ourselves by not
doing that i think things like
certain kinds of over-parenting
certain kinds of over-scheduling
children you know i talk to kids these
days about like what they do i do some
community work with children and i talk
to like some kids about
you know what's their summer like and
they're saying oh you know i go to band
camp then i'm at you know algebra class
and blah blah blah they have a full
schedule they're busier than i am during
their summers right that's a huge change
in society you know generational change
versus what it was in the 1990s or early
2000s and you know maybe there are some
positive benefits for that maybe there's
some drawbacks but we have to be able to
look at both sides of it otherwise we're
only saying half the world and we could
be missing a lot of threats to our
children if we if we continue to to
address or threats to anyone else we
continue to address social problems in
that way
perspective i you know the difficulty is
the hysteria there's money to be made
for the media
when us you know a shooting happens the
media says this is big run it look at
look at i don't saw the project veritas
expose where they had the cnn guy being
like you know we just run the covet
death tracker because it plays well you
know it's like it was gangbusters for
the ratings
that's what they're thinking about and
it drives panic and panic you never want
to panic you panic you cause problems if
you're in a fire the last thing you want
to do is panic you want to be calm
rational be like okay here's what i got
to do here's how i got i got to feel the
door i'm going to get down get under the
smoke all that stuff
instead the media just screams in
everyone's faces at the top of their
lungs screaming panic and then people
panic and then they click more and then
they get more you know they make more
money they make more ads they get more
subscriptions
and it all ends up you know going into
every facet of society it's not just the
media it's now in like uh
regular businesses it's in the medic
it's in like movie theaters it's in uh
um burger joints yeah i mean
and look like panic is part of human
nature for a reason it's an evolutionary
response if you see a saber-toothed
tiger maybe it might be a good idea to
to run in dart in the other way well but
for me to be honest if i saw a
saber-toothed tiger that'd be cool i
mean like whoa that's where they were
extinct that's true
um but that kind of evolutionary
response or instinct is only useful in
some select circumstances where you're
really seeing a direct threat in front
of you
complex social problems really never
really they never really benefit from
panicking and if you think about like
who we think of as the great leaders
throughout history whether they're
generals or theologians or activists or
so on and so forth they generally had a
calm thoughtful reasoned response to the
social problems they were dealing with i
mean
we admire the
sclc and snick and king's movement
when if you actually look at some of the
old photos and i think it's actually
still exist the highly under center in
tennessee where they were training civil
rights activists they would have people
sitting at like a lunch counter a mock
lunch counter someone will be pulling
their hair another person would be
blowing smoke in their face and they
would train them just to like brush it
off just say i don't care i'm going to
keep keep on the course of action right
that's those are the those are the modes
of thinking or the temperament that you
have to adopt when you're dealing with
really complex high pressure problems at
times and i think treating everything
like it's you know the bear just walked
into your camp and you better you better
dart uh leads you astray a lot of the
time and unfortunately i think that we
have so much technology and so much of
the commercial products that we use
today are basically based on using that
kind of response because that's what
they want to bring out of you because
that's what that's what will make the
money
yeah well i don't know how you how do
you break that right if if we i guess
that's a problem of of the free market
right that this system in place makes
money
so it is being incentivized you know
i'll go back to what i was saying about
the algorithms feeding kids this this
endless stream of police brutality stuff
well
companies rose it's very simple company
a and company b start up company a does
legit fact check journalism company b
does rage bait activist stuff which one
made the money
so over over the course of uh six months
the real news website does decently and
the grifter outrage site makes tons of
money and then the investors come in and
say
well that one makes money let's do that
one and now it's been a decade of this
it's been 13 14 15 years of this and now
we've built this massive ecosystem of
hey we make money when we just tell
people what they want to hear instead of
informing them of the truth
it's not only that they make money doing
that i mean well it's not only that it
generates money it generates revenue but
it's also very quick and easy to do
think about how many articles you read
that's like you know three people
tweeted something
it's mildly offensive but by time you
figure
by time you get through the article it's
going to be super offensive this would
be like the worst thing in the world to
you um it's super easy to run that
article it probably gets hundreds of
thousands of views if you're putting it
up there it doesn't you don't have to
spend money on investigating spec
checking traveling you know foia records
request none of that work it's extremely
easy and i think that's part of why it's
profitable because i do think that like
well-produced good journalism does get a
lot of viewers and readers i think
people enjoy it and appreciate it but
it's also more expensive to do right
which is a challenge i think for a lot
of people who are producing it and
investing in it and unfortunately i
think that's also created a situation
where like a lot of good media isn't
necessarily profitable we are kind of
like at the behest of like
philanthropists and billionaires who
want to spend money promoting something
uh like pierre mittier did with the
interceptor like peter thiel is doing
with some like alternative video
platforms or things like that i don't i
don't think it's all bad uh there was an
episode that uh of joe rogan's show he
did and i think it may have been with
matt tybee i'm not sure where they
mentioned like anybody who goes for
legit journalism right now is probably
gonna make a killing you know it's and
and we're already seeing with all these
different sub stacks popping up i mean
glenn greenwald you have substance
michael tracy for instance matt taibi
and apparently they're doing really uh
barry weiss yeah they're all doing
really really well i mean timcast.com is
doing uh is doing really really well
and so
i will say there's always a challenge in
trying to figure out if you're actually
doing the right job or if you're just
you know partisan but i i think it's
fair to point out
yeah the establishment is just pushing
narratives many of these outlets just
want to stick to their world view side
with the audience they call it and if
their audience is is trapped in a
whirlpool of fake news garbage and
hating someone else siding with the
audience isn't the right thing you want
to do no you want to challenge
well you know you want to challenge you
you want to be honest
so so interestingly you mentioned these
articles where it's like they'll grab a
few tweets and then post an article
being like you know so and so said this
we've actually talked about this at
timecast.com because we've had a few
articles where it's like so-and-so was
criticized and then we show some tweets
and i'm like
we won't do that and i was like hey
let's talk about this is this is it
might be newsworthy to be fair it might
be because if like a congressperson
makes an official statement about a
specific policy that starts a feud or
something and then it's just you're
pulling tweets that may be something
people want to know about but i said
what we should do is
if we see one of these twitter spats
we're not just going to pull up someone
on the right who's saying you know fu i
want to see what the left you know
prominent personalities are saying and
the right and then we want to actually
break down the fact check of who's right
and who's wrong
now that's a little bit more work you
got to actually do some journalism there
but that's the way it should be
conversations are happening on twitter
very important ones it's kind of silly
in some ways but if a congress person is
debating another congress person i think
you know we want to talk about that look
i think part of it also just like
awareness i think we were
i did some work earlier this year for a
guy named justin rosenstein he was an
early google and facebook guy he also
co-founded asana he made like i don't
know he's like probably a billionaire
worth of his asana stock and facebook um
and
his conclusion was that he created all
these technologies to help people
cooperate with each other and work
together as teams but they all kind of
went awry everyone hates each other
there's a lot of division and everything
so basically he's giving away a ton of
money through philanthropy and grant
making because he feels guilty about all
this
um i think that
you know he started this company with he
started these companies with like good
intentions like he was one of the
founders of like the facebook like
button and like i think that they
actively debated whether or not to make
a dislike button but they were like
we're not going to do that because it'll
be negative it'll create negativity
people will get fighting and all that
stuff and but it ended up facebook like
ended up like being pretty bad anyway
because people are using it to share
content this was like dissing someone or
attacking some out group or something
but i think that
you know there are large social and
cultural changes that happen once you're
aware that something is a problem and i
don't think that we looked at
you know the
youtubes and the social medias of the
world and sort of the echo chambers
hybrid polarization all this as a
problem until very recently i think even
if you go back to like 2009 2010
everyone was talking about how these
things were great we were all
communicating with each other uh they
were helping democrats in elections so
democrats liked them versus how they
felt about trump using it in 2016-15-16
or him using twitter
but i think now that we have the
awareness of the problem i kind of feel
like the solutions will bubble up
as
after the awareness is built because i
think that's what's happened with other
technologies that ended up being harmful
for us i think everything from we have
much safer cars now with seat belts and
airbags
to where we have a dramatic decline in
smoking in the united states right
smoking was an addictive product people
was flying off the shelves making people
at altria and so on and so forth tons
and tons of money but i think once we
recognized that it was a problem start
educating people about it
creating some alternatives some minor
regulations i think we actually moved in
a healthier direction and i think
something similar will happen with
social media and a lot of what online
you know
monopolization has done to journalism
and part of that i think is anti-trust
like getting very serious about the fact
that these companies basically are the
new standard oil they are the new
railroads and that creating alternatives
to them and creating healthier modes and
models is very very difficult while they
have such high market share and i think
more democrats and republicans uh in in
the congress you have david salini who's
the head of the relevant committee in
congress on antitrust and ken buck who's
the ranking republican actually agreeing
on a lot of the core antitrust issues
with a lot of these big companies
it was funny that like i think a third
of the republicans in the senate voted
for lena khan to join the the ftc who's
a very progressive person who in many
ways has talked about breaking up
companies like amazon or turning them
into public utilities or having utility
regulation uh instead so i think that
we're seeing much more agreement that
these things are a problem and some
agreement on solutions now does that
mean i think that a year or two from now
we're gonna have an entirely different
uh online and social media environment
which i think ultimately would impact
the media environment no but i do think
over the long term having that awareness
and having that recognition is the first
step towards creating something better
this is different though right with with
these past things that were bad for us
asbestos and smoking and lead gas and
stuff like that i mean that was
neutral-ish you it was public interest
versus the special interest that had
money around a specific product or
practice
now you got half the country
so if we're talking about censorship and
you have this major shift where all of a
sudden the the you know more
establishment like i mean like the
neocons and the democrats are basically
in favor of massive multinational
corporations curtailing speech
i don't see us fixing that because that
directly impacts who gets elected in the
first place when jack dorsey can ban
negative news about hunter biden
well then hunter biden's dad gets
elected and depending on what you
believe i mean there was a there was a
survey from rasmussen which found that
if people had been informed because
people didn't know about this when they
learned that hunter biden had done these
things with joe and these these shady
business deals they would not have voted
for him the margin was massive or large
enough to actually question you know it
was like 10 of people said they wouldn't
have voted for biden had they known the
truth well we know that facebook and
twitter suppress negative news about a
democratic candidate
that being the case
why would any democrat ever
give in to any kind of legislative
reform over these companies the
antitrust stuff i can see
yes
i don't think i'll solve the problem
though what people need to understand
about facebook and google is that
antitrust makes sense simply because
we're not you know some people say oh
but you know who wants to use a bunch of
different video platforms i'm not saying
that youtube is a video platform
adsense is an advertising platform
adwords is is a is an ad uh distribution
platform i mean they're i think they
change that not not just google ads or
whatever but these are all different
products
youtube hosts your video and broadcasts
it
google sells ads on that
google buys you know buys and sells ads
and distrib and distributes them they
also market your content to maximize
viewership these are different companies
in the past you would find someone
record your music you'd find someone to
distribute your mu distribute your music
and then you would find people to
promote your music on the radio today
youtube that's it
youtube hosts and distributes they're
the ones who do all the ad selling and
they're the ones who determine who's
going to be on the front page you could
break them up into three companies
antitrust could come in and say
you know everybody likes youtube because
it's where the videos are okay youtube
you no longer can do the ads we're
breaking this up into different
companies and then all of a sudden you'd
see way more competition and ad rates
probably ad rates would improve
dramatically for a lot of people you
would then get sp you you would then get
people at youtube basically being like
you know uh
this would be interesting because there
would have to be individual deals with
your channel and youtube as to how
revenue is generated it'd be very very
complicated it may actually even destroy
youtube because i don't know if youtube
is possible if youtube can even function
without subsidy from google in the first
place but that
if that's the case there's a lot of
questions we have to ask about
major companies making tons of money
doing one thing subsidizing and cutting
everyone else from the market by dumping
money into another thing right
so a better example is
i won't name the big chain of coffee
houses of coffee shops just for legal
reasons but
i've heard these stories from local mom
and pop cafes where a big chain shop
opens up next door and sells coffee at
ridiculous prices ridiculously low
because they're well funded by a massive
conglomerate they can sell at a loss
it chokes out the mom and pop shop
because now all of a sudden you've got
people like why spend five bucks on my
cap you know cappuccino when chain store
has it for three bucks
then once mom and pop goes out of
business
chain store jacks the prices back up and
now owns 100 of that market share
though that that that's problematic
that's predatory behavior that we see a
lot of i know a lot of people on the
right say that simply just oh it's free
market capitals when they're allowed to
do it and i'm like
i mean that's brutal that's basically
what youtube does
google just dumps money into these
things so facebook for instance the same
thing right facebook is a social network
as well as advertisement advertising
sales and promotion marketing all of
these things i think we could look at
that and find a way to break it apart
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 p.m where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you